so who wants to play a game
[Applause]
[Music]
patreon sponsored review and man you
guys got me reading again how crazy is
that
this one I got commissioned to read the
book player of games by Iain M banks
Iain M banks is a science fiction writer
whose work I was not familiar with I'd
never read any of it or like I knew his
name in that like I think I'd seen his
name on a book but I knew really nothing
about him or his work or really anything
so unlike the last one I did which was
monstrous my regimen by Terry Pratchett
I did at least know who Pratchett was
never read something that he did this
one coming in pretty much completely
cold now player of games is the second
book in a series of books called the
culture books the culture is a future
society that banks created that's it's
kind of Lee utopia it's kind of it's I
mean it's not dissimilar from the Star
Trek Federation as depicted in say the
next generation you know when it
actually was kind of a functioning
utopia which it hasn't been for a really
long time actually in Star Trek stuff
but anyways it's it's a post need
society all basic necessities are a
given no one has to worry about food
water shelter companionship if they
wanted nobody is neat nobody is left
wanting for the basics so people can
actually basically develop whatever it
is they actually have a passion for and
this particular book which is the second
in the series but I honestly think it
picks up and reaches fine as it is
focuses on a character named Gergely I
think that's how you pronounce it
there's a lot of long and weird names in
this book so some of which I'm probably
not even gonna remember others of which
I'm probably gonna butcher so just heads
up on that
so Gergely is the titular player of
games now the first thing worth noting
on this normally when you think
five future setting because this the the
culture is a spacefaring future society
you would think games you know Oh
virtual reality all these plug you into
our mind things like this was written in
the 80s so that wasn't the standard yet
that actually wasn't really much of a
thing yet you kind of had to wait for
William Gibson to get the ball rolling
on that he may or may not have written
something like that by now but it wasn't
the standard wasn't the norm because you
know video games were like this was
original NES days this thing was
published they were super simplistic so
the games being played are in the more
classical sense they're on a board
they're pieces there are cards there are
things like that being moved and
manipulated around physically in the
world so we're not talking high-tech
games but we are still talking
potentially very complicated games now
Gergely is someone who both not only
plays games but also designs them he is
actually designed some of the more
complex games played in the culture and
as a character he honestly if the
narrative wasn't structured the way that
it was he would probably be a bit
insufferable because he is
self-important he's a bit aloof he's
borderline elitist he just he's jaded
you know he's a he is unimpressed by
anything and it's the only way that a
character like that works is if you
throw them into a situation where they
are not familiar you throw them off
their game you turn them into an
underdog which is exactly what this
story does thankfully so the set up is
Wow
oh boy trying to think of how to explain
this because the actual mechanics the
plot mechanics of how we get to the main
thrust of the story are a little bit
complicated so I'm not gonna go through
all the nuts and bolts of those but
ultimately what ends up happening but
I'm getting into how we get here Gergely
is effectively recruited by the culture
to be an envoy to this Empire and to
play their game and their game is so
intrinsic to the society that it
is representative of the society itself
it's called as ad and it and actually
the the Empire is named after the game
that's how interlinked they are who the
emperor is is determined by the victor
of a tournament of people who play this
game it is in many ways structure and
design to represent the Empire as a
whole this is a big deal to this Empire
and they're aware of the culture but
they don't know all the details the
culture is very wary of what they
consider to be barbarian civilizations
knowing too much about them and how they
operate and so he is sent as an envoy to
go and you know interact a bit with the
Empire and to attempt to play their game
now it is basically like the idea is
that he'll basically be in what would be
the equivalent of exhibition matches
technically he's being entered into the
tournament but it you know no one's
expecting much she's supposed to go
there you know learning a bit have some
fun and you know come back but he does
better than he or the culture and
definitely the Empire expect him to and
that's the main thrust of the story as
he works his way through this tournament
and then it builds to its ultimate
climax so that's the basic structure of
where we're going and actually
structures a good place to start because
it's one of the strengths of this book
it is very well structured in terms of
the overall pace of how long it spends
in each segment and to move forward it
spends just enough time in the culture
before you know bundling him off and
then it actually sticks with the journey
as he gets to know that his primary
companions of when he's gonna be over
there I'll come back to them and then
act and then you know a chunk of time
learning the early parts of the game and
then as things escalate getting a better
sense of the Empire getting to the
climax so the the structure as I said is
very well laid out because we basically
get just enough of each thing and Iain M
banks I'm about to say something about
his writing that normally doesn't work
for me but he seems to have just enough
self-awareness to understand to not let
this overtake his writing he seems to be
a very technically minded writer and
what I
say that what I mean is he has a lot of
focus on the little details of exactly
you know the the intricacies of how this
piece of equipment works how this game
works how this society works the nuts
and bolts little technical details very
much come through his writing as being
the thing that he is most interested in
and in the hands of a less self-aware
writer that could lead to something that
I personally wouldn't enjoy because I
don't like getting bogged down in
technical details I like to get the gist
of what's going on and have more of a
focus on the forward momentum and the
emotionality of the story and this story
is not devoid of those things because
E&M Bank seems to know well enough that
as much as there is a lot of technical
details he doesn't forget to move the
story forward
and I actually was nervous going into
this because the the patronize er who
commissioned me for this actually
directed me to a blog post that Iain M
banks I wrote some time ago basically
describing the culture the history of it
and how the society works and I was
advised to read that before reading the
book and I tried I got about two
paragraphs and I'm like I can't read
this and it made me very very very
nervous because I was afraid that that
blog entry was going to be
representative of the book but it's not
that blog entry was essentially just a
just an encyclopedic history of how the
culture works how it functions and I
just I can't absorb information like
that my brain checks out very quickly I
like to take in that information in
context through character interactions
like a little bit of exposition where
it's necessary but largely just to pick
up how it works and because that's how I
took in this story also be aware that if
I say anything wrong about how the
culture works as a society it's probably
because the details that I'm getting
wrong weren't in this book were covered
somewhere else or were covered in
encyclopedic entries about them but that
encyclopedic entry also again says a lot
of idnum banks and how his mind works in
that and the level of detail that he has
worked out in the fine minutia that he
knows about he knows this society like
the back of his hand
but like I said he does a very good job
of balancing how
much of that detail to actually put in
the narrative and he never do rails the
narrative in order to cram in more
details he comes close a couple times
but he doesn't quite go over the edge
into actually de railing anything so
power to him there
um the characters I mentioned Gergely
could have been insufferable in a
different narrative here he does work I
never fell in love with him he I mean
I'm not sure you're supposed to he's not
designed to be a particularly endearing
character but he was a character that
once he was taken out of his element and
put somewhere else where he was on the
backfoot and trying to learn you know
what's going on around him and how
everything works I was able to relate
him enough that he worked for me
functioning as a protagonist the much
more interesting characters or at least
a much more fun characters actually tend
to be the drones because in the culture
there are robotic drones that are kind
of servants but they have rights they
have autonomy they have emotions in this
story they're actually far more likely
to just be more fun they're more likely
to swear and just have they tend to have
more personality
the main drone that we spend time with
because this is the one that Gergely
travels with over to the Empire is FLIR
emza ho again apologies if I'm getting
these right but there's a few of there's
more in skalle earlier on and these are
like they've got very different
personalities but I love that the
machines have that degree of personality
I mean like is one of the things I love
about something like Hitchhiker's Guide
to the galaxy in Star Wars
I love machines that have that much just
inner uniqueness in terms of how they
interact with people that it doesn't
feel like an algorithm just replying so
that's all there and I like all that so
as far as some other stuff goes that I
think in some ways this book shows its
age and normally when you say that a
science fiction story shows its age
usually you tend to think man is like oh
well like the predictions of what the
technology would be we've caught up to
it or it just seems quaint or
what-have-you like you go back and watch
the original Star Trek they've got the
tricorder and it does take you long to
realize like that thing's got maybe half
the functions of an iPhone and looks
worse but no it's not like that the way
in which it's dated is that some of the
ideas
in here in terms of some elements of the
culture and also of the Empire they are
ideas that at the time the thing was
published were probably pretty novel
ideas I'm not gonna go so far as to say
he and M banks would have been the first
writer to use them but they would have
been fresh enough that just having them
present was kind of enough but he
doesn't always explore the implications
of these ideas properly which is the
sort of thing you tend to see either
from later work from the same author or
sometimes later work from authors who
were inspired by by by the originator
who look at and go oh let's let's really
drill into that and some of the good
examples here have to do with some of
the structure of how gender works both
in the culture and in the Empire because
the the Empire actually has three
genders there's women men and apices or
if it's a singular an apex and the thing
is though it is still basically a
hierarchal society where certain genders
are have more inherent Authority than
others and they just put apices at the
top abcs men women and so it's not
really a condition of a third gender in
the Empire doesn't really upend the
gender dynamics so much as add one more
person to put at the top on top of whom
normally is but other than that it
doesn't really change that things that
much from what you would expect from an
extremely patriarchal society is just an
APIs airy society like I don't know what
the word would be but other than that
it's not that different from what you'd
expect to see in a science fiction or
fantasy story with an extreme
male-dominated society and when it comes
to the culture they actually have the
ability through various glands and
whatnot that they that they have the
ability to manipulate to actually change
themselves from male to female not just
like a parents like full-blown it takes
a little mile couple weeks month or so
but it is possible for a man to become a
woman in order to bear a child and then
become a man again and you know it it's
that is an inch
idea but frustratingly it doesn't really
seem to alter the core gender dynamics
between men and women because you would
think in a society where gender
effectively is meaningless and something
that anybody has the ability to change
that you wouldn't have as much standard
gender dynamics in terms of interactions
as we end up getting in this story to be
fair Gergely is the only character whose
inner thoughts were we are privy to so
maybe he is is outdated in his mode of
thinking but that doesn't really track
either because he still grew up in the
society of that it's like this but his
thoughts on women relationships and that
sort of thing are all very of the time
it was written so what it feels like is
E&M banks had this idea for how gender
could be different and then just stuck
in him but didn't do the follow through
of oh if that was different
how would that affect things in terms of
the dynamics and the relationships and
he didn't take that extra step so that
it's dated in that sort of ways like
there are ideas here that I would hope
he explored better in in later entries
but in this story they're like it's a
little anachronistic the way some things
are sort of handled the other thing
that's a little weird is the ending is
the climax it's not bad but it is a
little off and I'm not gonna go into
extreme detail but it is gonna get a
little bit pseudo spoilery cuz I'm gonna
make an analogy that'll at least give
you an idea of the vibe of the ending so
it in many ways this is structurally
like a sports rivalry film you know
that's he's learning the game he's
playing the game he has an ultimate
opponent he's gonna be fighting at the
end at the end of the tournament so it's
got that structure and to explain why
the end of it so the natural climax of
that kind of story is the final
confrontation sports calm for
of whatever the sport is and this came
the game of as add between your hero and
whoever they're trying to take on
whether that person's like a proper
villian or just you know who their
opponent is battle vary from story to
story but like that's the natural climax
of this and the story does kind of
climax around that but then it throws
this other stuff in there as well I
don't know this is just up and try and
make it more exciting but if feels like
it kind of comes out of nowhere like the
component pieces makes sense it's not a
deus ex machina but it's like that
wasn't necessary so like imagine if
somebody made somebody wrote a book or
made a movie that focused you know that
was set say during the Cold War and it
focused on a chess player from the US
and the Soviet Union and the whole story
was you know the two of them either
working towards each other or like this
person wins this game the design you're
building up to the climactic chess match
between these two and as that chess
match concludes the building that it's
happening in is subject to a bomb raid
like aerial bombardment hey what that's
the kind of the vibe of the climax of
this thing it's a little weird and I
don't think it was necessary like I get
why it's there for sort of things we
learned during what I would consider to
be the coda of the whole story but it's
a little odd and also I think we might
be dealing partially with the case of
Iain M banks being a little too in love
with his own creation by that I mean the
culture as a society because one of the
interesting things that was going on
early on is because this game is so
embedded into the society that is the
Empire as Gergely was learning it better
his frame of mind actually started to
alter he started to think more like the
members of the Empire thought and that
actually brought in some interesting
questions about how malleable are the
members of the culture and when they
have this kind of utopic existence when
you take them out of that how
corruptible are they and those are the
questions that kind of get raised but
then we learn additional details about
the empire that seemed base
designed just to ensure that the Empire
is clearly worse than the culture it's
because without these additional details
that get learned about two-thirds of the
way and in terms of how the internal
workings of the Empire work and some of
the stuff that goes on there I'm not
gonna say that they were on even footing
but the Empire doesn't seem that much
worse than the culture just different
and like maybe the culture is just being
super judgy but then we get these these
like oh no the Empire is really actually
terrible and here's why and that also
kind of feels unnecessary because I feel
like it removes some ambiguity that I
was enjoying like again not totally
ambiguity but a little of huh makes you
think but then it very clearly
villainized this one side of this what
could have been a more openly
philosophical conflict and you know it
made me go oh you kind of took a little
bit of the complexity out with that and
I know a fair amount of this review has
been me sort of saying the things that
didn't quite work but honestly
especially for the time that it was
written I think this is a pretty dang
solid piece of work so I'd say if you're
partial to 80s era sci-fi where a lot of
these ideas were being tried for the
first time but maybe weren't getting
fully explored yet if you have a
nostalgia for that time I think it's
worth giving a read and even before it's
false it still reads pretty well it's a
well-told narrative like I said that
structure and pacing of it are really
solid and they do a lot to help it
overcome some of the dated miss and some
of the lost potential in terms of some
of its ideas that it doesn't quite
explore it still tells a pretty good
story that ultimately is what I'm after
at the end of the day like all the
trappings of everything and how you know
in the the world and the all the
intricacies like that's nice but if I'm
not enjoying the story you're telling I
don't really care it's just pretty
wrapping on nothing but it's got a solid
story so all this other stuff is just
additional flavor for it and that might
do it for you I'm not like hooked in I
don't see myself like voluntarily for
fun reading the other books in this
series but
I again if any of the sound that
appealing to you it's well worth giving
it a look so player of games have you
read it or have you read any of the
other books by this author or in this
series whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's a whole bunch of
stuff to you because there's buttons and
likes which are I guess are big now they
keep changing the algorithm but
subscribe I'd appreciate it patreon
appreciate that even more plus there's
links to merch and my social media stuff
all that stuff is down in the
description give a look click on buttons
or don't I'm not gonna say you have to
because at the end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings so until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]